okay chair you're now live
right it's two o'clock and i would like
to welcome you all to this virtual
meeting of audit and governance
committee
on the 30th of march and i'll just go
through some of the basic rules for the
meeting
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones except for mine
please leave all microphones muted
unless you're asked to speak
right
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or proposal second emotion
please press the raise the hand symbol
in the reactions menu on your screen
these are shown on my screen in the
order they are pressed
and i will deal with them in the order
given
the appropriate officer or counsellor
the opportunity to answer in between
where necessary
i will also return to the councillor to
check that they are happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out
and muting muting your microphone as
necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency
with the democratic process this meeting
is being
live streamed on the council's youtube
channel
we are in unprecedented times and i ask
you all to be patient during this
meeting
and to understand the processes and
advice may take
longer than usual right
so on to the agenda and first of all the
register of attendance
so over to kirsty
thank you chair counselor craigie
yeah mr hackett here
councillor heppel present councillor
hodgson
president councillor jones
president and councillor rossi has given
his apologies chair
thank you very much kirsty right
item two is confirmation of minutes
to confirm the minutes the meeting held
on the 22nd of september
2020 and that's on pages three to twelve
so we just do a quick page turner um
pages three
four 5
6 7
8 9
10 11 and finally page
12. so i'm happy to um
propose those from the chair so i'm
looking for a seconder
oh i've
castle hudson claire seconding so we'll
go back to
a recorded vote
thank you chad thank you councillor
craigie
four thank you councillor hackett for
councillor heppell for council hudson
for councillor jones
sorry am i mistaken on my agenda i have
confirmation of the minutes for the 26th
of january 2021
not not september am i am i missing
something here
i think the slider on the presentation
correct
yes so is is the um is the one on the
agenda incorrect then no
the agenda is correct it was the 26th of
january as our last ordinance and
governance meeting
so are we sorry are you voting to
approve oh sorry voting now to approve
27th september
i am yeah i'm for that thank you
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much kirsty
all right we will move on to item
three which is the action list
right the first item is minute number
one two one
raised by council hodson um
as we see it's been completed
and the second item counselor craigie
about the pension scheme and david hayes
has
taken that action and that's been
completed
right are we yes claire
yeah um item one two one doesn't
actually say
uh it says stacy to follow it doesn't
say it's completed
on um on here
um but i did have a conversation with
stacy
who reassured me that the processes in
place
allowed for information exchange and
that there was no
blockage in
exchange of information regarding the
safety of
any individual so i'm quite happy to
say that i've had a satisfactory
response to that but it doesn't actually
note
it in the action list
right okay stacy you'd like to come in
there
yeah just to um assure um committee
members we just had a safeguarding audit
undertaken um it's the report's in um
draft format at the moment but it's a
very positive report
so hopefully that goes some way as well
to usher with councillor hudson in
relation to
our procedures and processes
right okay can i just see
clarification on the the slide in the
minutes that we had
um i have before me the minute stated
the 26th of january
on the on the actual slide itself it
said the 22nd which i read out for
september
yeah i think it was a clerical on the
slide chair right
so you've taken the vote for the january
minutes which is correct
okay that's fine
right yes thank you
on the minutes then i i thought we were
voting on as a
as i understood it the september minutes
i say i i don't want to vote for
the minutes of um january because i
wasn't at that meeting
yeah completely understand
that's fine we can mark it down as
abstain councillor jones for that one
for january
great thank you that's brilliant thank
you
right so that's dealt with those items
on the action list
moving on to the declaration of interest
item four members with interest to
declare
should refer to the agenda item describe
the nature of their interests when the
item is being discussed
item five agreements with gender items
part one and two
we do have an agenda item that is in
part two this afternoon or two agenda
items
so i'm going to go back to and have
a recorded vote on this
okay over to you kirsty um mr chairman
i'm happy to
the professor and second up i was just
going i was just thinking i'm happy to
close
from the chair so second uh our second
catheter hodgson thank you thank you
chair
councillor craigie or councillor hackett
for councillor heppell or
councillor hudson or councillor jones
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much
so item six urgent matters of
information to be brought forward with
the permission of the chair
i do not have any this afternoon
so now on to item seven which is a
torrid progress report to receive a
report from grant thornton
our external auditors pages 14 to 28 on
your agenda
and i'll pass over to the representative
from grant thornton
okay thank you very much indeed and good
afternoon councillors um just by
by way of introduction really um my name
is
julie mashee um i'm a director within
grand thornton
and um i recall that um alex did
uh highlight at the the last um audit
committee that there would be a change
of engagement lead for the 2020-21 audit
um just as a bit of context as to as to
why that audit
that change was necessary um as part of
our requirements
in terms of auditor independence we're
required across our whole portfolio of
audits to
to review the length of time both our
engagement leads and our managers
um are required to um to stay on
particular audits um in order to
maintain our
standards of independence um and because
of other changes elsewhere in the
portfolio um within grand thornton
we had to shuffle around a few of our
audits and and as such that's that's why
i've been introduced introduced to this
audit so um just a bit of background
uh as far as introduction from from my
perspective
um i've worked within the public sector
uh uh
as an auditor for it this is my 20th
year this year
um work a lot um within the districts
across devon so i do the audit for
um devon county council devon pension
fund and some other districts within the
devon area so
no lots of uh lots of people um across
the region
generally um and um just just really to
say chair very much working
looking forward to to working with you
and building relationships with with the
with the audit committee so um
yeah looking forward to um continuing
that engagement
um so in terms of the the report that
you have in
in front of you um this is our progress
report
um and so there's a couple of items just
really to draw to your attention
from that progress support um a couple
of things just to close off
for 2019-20 so i think at the time that
alex reported to the last committee
um the work in relation to our housing
benefits audit was
still in the process of being finalized
that work has now been concluded and was
submitted
um to the dwp so that that effectively
now closes our 1920 work
so my focus obviously now has been uh on
working with the team to progress the
2021 audit um i'm pleased to say that
the the interim planning side of that
audit is progressing well
um we're working through our risk
assessment and getting an update in
terms of understanding of your systems
and the team has been working with with
david and colleagues to
to to make sure we update that
understanding um i think the main thing
to draw
out to committee members in terms of
changes is around the change to the
value for money
uh requirements this year so effectively
the national audit office um issued
a an updated code of audit practice that
came into effect from last april
and with that has introduced a brand new
sort of framework
around the work of value for money
so um for the for the benefit of um for
those
committee members who are not as
familiar with with the process um in
previous years
alongside the the main opinion that
we've given on your financial statements
we also gave a separate uh opinion on
your value for money arrangements and
that was a sort of binary conclusion in
terms of
qualified unqualified um effectively now
that
that qualification position has now has
now gone under the new framework so we
don't
issue a conclusion as such now alongside
the accounts in the way that we used to
um and and the breadth of the work um
that is now required under the new code
is is a lot broader so effectively
where um in previous years we looked at
and undertook a risk assessment
identified
particular areas um where we had to
undertake further inquiries and then
just report by exception
if there were any issues um under the
new framework effectively uh we're
required to look at arrangements across
the authority
under under three key pillars um one is
on financial sustainability
one is on governance and the third one
is iran around
ensuring economy efficiency and
effectiveness
and the reporting side of it has changed
to sort of go with that so
we're in the past that we would just
report by exception um to say if there
were any issues or concerns
um it now requires a much more informed
broader narrative giving you positive
assurance on all things that are working
well
as well as those areas which require any
scope for improvement
in the arrangements if we have a
situation then where we
identify that there are significant
weaknesses in those arrangements under
the new code we're required under the
requirements to
issue what we call um a a key
recommendation so for any
any area of a significant weakness there
is a key recommendation
we're required to report but the report
the
newer broader report it does give a
scope to give you
any other wider improvement
opportunities um as well
so um effectively how that that will
then play out in terms of the committee
program for this year
we'll still present you with an audit
finance report on the accounts
um later this year that gives the
conclusions on the financial statements
but then in terms of the vfm reporting
um they've now replaced the annual audit
letter
with a separate annual auditors report
that will be an all-encompassing report
reporting back on our value for money
findings um
the expectation of the no is that will
be presented alongside
the findings on the accounts but we will
be separate to that that you've
typically been used to as part of the
audit finance report
um so as i said in terms of our progress
for the 2021 work i
i'm i'm pleased with the progress that
we're making so far in terms of our
interim planning
we've discussed um this the timetable
around the the year-end account and
we're looking to come in to to this
authority
early in the process um so yeah very
um very pleased with how things are
progressing chair but um just
just happy to take any specific
questions on the report if there are any
david hayes you wish to speak hi julie
uh thanks for that um
really this is for my benefit and i've
been a bit cheeky i probably should ring
you separately on this one
in terms of when you said um you check
us on financial
uh viability that's fine we do a
medium-term financial strategy
and actually fortuitously the members
made some very tough decisions this year
to
increase certain charges which is
certainly hopefully puts us on an even
keel going forward
governance arrangements well you've
always done that
in terms of how we manage our affairs
it's the efficiency economy and
effectiveness i'm just curious as to how
you'd actually
audit the council for that what sort of
things would you be looking what sort of
things should i be worried about julie
yeah sure um what i can do is i can i
can send round um
some some links to the actual um
guidance that the
the neo has issued under agno three
auditor guns note three
um which talks about some of the
specific sub criteria that effectively
cover is covered under um each of the
three pillars including that three years
aspect
but in particular the threes aspect is
looking around
um how the car the council is um
performing
in terms of how it's managing its cost
relative to performance so it's it's
it's particularly trying to identify
those areas which are
performing um well not so well um
those areas that are high cost services
to run low cost services run and how the
two
in effect link um it looks at how your
commissioning services and working with
partners to commission services to
deliver
um to to deliver services in them in the
most effective way
so we'll obviously be looking at some of
your your joint working arrangements
as well as part of that and is that
delivering uh what's
uh what it sets out to achieve um so so
that's kind of that's kind of
the main focus of of the three e's
because
and it's not it's not just about looking
at those hard numbers either so you say
for example we could look at
um some benchmarking data for a
particular authority
um and and identify that that particular
service is a high cost service
but actually there may be a story behind
that in terms of it's an area where you
know the council is putting a lot of
investment in because it wants to
bring service standards up to a certain
level or reshape the way it wants to
deliver that service going forward so
there may be legitimate reasons why
more money is going into a particular
service so as i said high cost doesn't
necessarily mean bad but it's important
that we we look at the raw data
uh around that um look at how the
council monitors his own performance
both financially and performance wise
and then draw some conclusions around
that so it is it is quite subjective
um but that's kind of the sort of the
basic premise of the the sub criteria
is particularly looking at cost versus
performance
does that help at all david yes
presumably only look you presumably be
looking at services where you've got
some
easily quantifiable so imagine like the
refuge service
there's a very easily quantifiable it's
a number of um
properties we collect from the amount of
tonnage that we collect so you could
compare the cost of that with an
authority
then obviously you'd have to bear in
mind that torrid would have a different
demographic in terms of being rural
compared to say
the center of manchester say for example
absolutely yeah exactly
sorry last question julie been hugging
you know when abouts in june are you
coming in the audit please
um so i i know you're gonna ask me the
specific dates i don't have them to hand
but
you are first in the queue effectively
so we've got a trap we've got a tranche
of audits i think it'll be towards it'll
be towards the
the last two weeks of june so
effectively we're doing nhs audits
um through to the middle of june um and
so as soon as those nhs audits are
completed we'll be looking to start our
local work
so you're in sort of trance one
effectively of that local government
work
okay right thank you thank you david
um julie first of all welcome to
the torridge team if you like thank you
um
i i know that um your office contacted
me about an informal meeting
beforehand it didn't take place but i'm
sure
with the pace of things going on at the
moment and that's understandable but i
i would appreciate a meeting with grant
thornton prior to
the actual meetings we have as always
the government committee just to get
that
firstly informal relationship and also
an in-depth discussion about
things that i might want to speak to you
about
that aren't appropriate for a committee
meeting um one of the things that
i would like to draw upon we've got
these three tiers now
yes the vfm are they as robust
as the old value for money report
so in terms of the criteria themselves
you mean that's right
can we get that assurance from the new
three
tiers that we used to have from the vfm
yes abs absolutely you can and and i
think um as i said this is this was the
whole intention i think of
um the neos changing approach is that it
wants to
trying to find a mechanism which adds
more value to an authority because what
typically you find with the old vfm
approaches we're almost kind of telling
you what what you know already in terms
of
those areas where we're reporting by
exception um
generally they are high on your risk
register um
they they are things that you know if
we're saying that there's something
wrong
it shouldn't come as a surprise as you
whereas that the whole
the whole concept around this new
approach and broadening the scope of
that and the reporting
is also trying to give some positive
assurance around the things that the
council are doing well
and and and as i said there is and it
does say somewhere in the in one of my
pages on the progress report
there is this different sort of scale of
recommendation
in that yes we may you know in some
authorities not
saying that there's tool for torrid but
in some authorities where we do find
significant weaknesses
you will have these key recommendations
there is
also scope within the reporting to then
provide other recommendations which is
generally meant to be
more in terms of supporting good
practice you know giving the council
ideas about how he could do things
differently whilst not meant to be
criticized and it's meant to be there to
be
trying to add wide value so um
absolutely the breadth of the work is is
is is far greater than before
um it will need to be conducted by more
senior members of the team so it'll be
more myself
and the audit manager that will
typically get involved in this sort of
work
you know operating and talking to
directors across the
uh authority at a strategic level so um
i very much hope that this
new approach will very much kind of be
more robust and add value to this
committee
um but i said it's you one we've got to
see how it how it pans out in in this
first year
we're all trying to um get that
understanding that familiarity with with
with the new approach
but it's also important to assure the
committee that you know there is still
going to be
a moderation exercise that we will
maintain internally within grand thorns
and you know
we look after 40 of the local government
market and so it's really important that
where we're making specific judgments
and comparing arrangements across
different authorities that we are
moderating what we're doing
and we're sort of comparing that to what
authorities elsewhere are doing to make
sure that we're not being
unduly generous or harsh about what
judgments we're making about different
councils so
as i said first year will be a bit of a
trial run to see to see how it pans out
but um
i'm certainly if if if the nao's
intentions of all this is is seeking to
be fulfilled i i would hope that
the committees get a lot of value more
value out of this process
okay from our point of view it's going
to give us that assurance
that we can have confidence in and the
one thing you touched on it before
the timeline i hear things are
progressing well but if there is any
slippage
could you bring it back to the audit
committee at the earliest opportunity
and let me know by email and david
obviously and his team
so that we know where we stand with it
okay that's fantastic
i see that um cancer craig is rated at
hand so
over to you ruth you'd like to come in
thank you chair hello julie hello ruth
um what i'd like to ask is because i'm
on the climate change committee
and so we are interested in obviously
a lot of different things um to make
sure that the council
has got a green agenda for example
procurement
and um recycling etc
and this may put costs up so will
when you're doing the value for money
statement are you just going to look
entirely at the costs
or are you going to look at the benefits
that we
are getting by being greener i.e less
carbon
will that count as better value or was
it just
financially do we want to go with the
cheapest of everything
no no it's a really really important uh
point ruth and i think
it's the starting point in all of this
will be
the council's corporate strategy its
corporate plan because
effectively you will have set out what
your priorities are as an organization
and so if we are seeing that that
authority
has has put um sort of the green agenda
high on its priority
it would be absolutely right that we
then see a pattern of how
you're um undertaking your plans uh
and discharging your plans and
priorities whether you you know
redirecting
um finances into those areas so that's
that's
absolutely right and it's important
therefore when we're having those
discussions
with your management team it's important
we understand that context because
and that's why it needs to be done at
that more senior a more experienced
level
in terms of us undertaking our our work
so yes
absolutely we're not as i said we're not
going to criticize necessarily an
authority just because you're spending
lots of money in an area
um it's more about us taking that raw
data
and just that's just enable us to start
a conversation about it and understand
what you're doing um because we're able
to access benchmarking data across lots
of different authorities
um if we know that you know we've got
similar authorities that
have um you know agree the green agenda
again you know both high on their agenda
you know we've got authorities a very
similar sort of population profile
and rule of profile yet this authority
is spending twice as much as this one
delivering fairly similar objectives
that might be where we want to challenge
one authority to say well hang on a
second
why is it costing you twice as much as
as this one
and and what benefit going back to
councillor hackett's point what benefit
that
they men entail in the future is
actually if if
if you're an example of an authority
that's doing something particularly well
or
if you're looking to prioritize a
particular area that we know there are
other authorities out there
that have some good practice that that
can be shared
it's all about connecting you up as well
in terms of you you taking that learning
from others and others taking that
learning from you so
this is where we think going forward as
as this new approach progresses
that's where some of the the added value
aspect might might come in it might
encourage more
um conversation and collaboration across
authorities as well based on what the
data is telling us
sorry that's a very long-winded way of
answering but as i said it's it's not
quite a straightforward
yes or no but it's just important that
sort of context
gives us the flexibility that's great
thanks yeah
and i think it sums up on something that
i read in the report saying more freedom
to reflect local context
that's fine and i think that
encapsulates it in a nutshell
right um yes back over to you julie to
continue
um i think that's it as far as my
progress report is concerned here so if
there's no other questions i'll move on
to the next item in the agenda
yes please do thank you okay so we're
now
moving on to um informing the audit risk
assessment and i suppose
it just an apology i suppose to to audit
committee members um because i think
i know from quite a few audit committees
that that i've already been to if you're
reading this
sort of cold first hand it can be it can
be quite weighty in terms of technical
terms and
quite a lot to take in so just for me to
try and demystify a little bit of that
if that would be helpful
so effectively as i said you know we're
making good progress at the moment
to to finalize our audit plan and get
our audit risk assessment ready for
2021.
um we have specific duties we have to
fulfill
under the um under the auditing
standards
and as the audit committee as those
charged with governance it's really
important that we follow
what the autism standards say to us
about how we engage with you as an audit
committee
to get your views and reflections around
certain aspects of how the council
operates
so so in particular the audit and
standards require us to talk to you
about
um the authority's compliance with laws
and regulations
it asks you to ask just to inquire to
you about whether you're aware of any
instances of suspected or actual fraud
within the authority
um it asks us to make sure that you are
understanding of
the key processes that the management
are going through in preparing the
accounts and what its
key policies and judgments are around
estimates
things like that and so normally we tend
to do these things a little bit sort of
kind of
haphazard so what we've tried to do is
try to encapsulate that all into one
single document this year which is this
informing the risk assessment document
that you have in front of you so
what we've effectively done is asked
david to provide
an initial response um from management
as to
what he believes are the arrangements in
place to consider all of those aspects
so really this is just coming to audit
committee now for you to
reflect on management's comments that
will come that has come back to us
um and really for your endorsements or
any comments or additional views that
you have on that so
if in reading this you think well hang
on a second i don't reckon you know
david says we've got this in place i
don't recognize that or
actually david mentioned this but he
forgot to mention all these other things
that we do as well
this is really just your opportunity to
um
uh to to really just give any sort of
final comments on that before we take
that into consideration as part of our
um
as part of our final risk planning so um
i hope that gives it a bit of
introduction and context but um
as i said i'm a po apologies it is a
little bit sort of jargony word to new
places but unfortunately that's because
that's what the auditing standards
require us to follow
okay that's fine councillor jones david
you'd like to come in
thank you chair um yeah i've read
through this it's a little bit of a
shame because the way the formatting is
it seems to cut off some of the wording
so i find it a little bit difficult to
follow in places
the only question i had was in relation
to page
35 where it mentions um
external solicitors
which the council uses and it says that
there weren't any
i understand that there were external
solicitors instructed
in relation to a matter and holsworthy
was that outside of the time frame for
this
or was it or should it have been
included
i don't know if david wants to come back
on that
yeah david david's trying to find page
35 councillor jones
bear with me
because you're right we have obviously
used external solicitors um
during the year so just let me just see
if i can find the question
and page 35. yeah general inquiries of
management
question eight
okay i finally found the page numbers
and see what you see council jonathan
cutting off of the uh yeah
where's the question sorry counselor
jones about the solicitor other than
in-house can you provide details are
these solicited pleases you could just
confirm
i actually thought sorry on that one i
thought um julia
um i'd have to go back to the original
document i thought we'd sent a link to a
little spreadsheet which actually listed
the payments we'd made to external
solicitors
so we had some solicitors engaged in nap
house during the course of the year
which was a legal case a health and
safety case with tragic death of a child
and i actually think we actually state
is going to come in but we actually sent
a little spreadsheet attachment i don't
know perhaps
something's gonna stray there quite
clearly we have used external solicitors
during the year
and i don't think uh
did you send that separately to the
audit team david as opposed to or did
you encounter
andrew davis i think councillor jones to
confirm we have used external solicitors
as a simple answer
and i believe we sent a little
spreadsheet attachment somewhere
probably without being a hyperlink
something's gone astray
i think stacy just wanted to come in at
this juncture yeah yeah stacy taken
yeah just to confirm david's correct and
i think it was
uh peter actually david who compiled the
spreadsheet
because it came up um to me for checking
and see if there's any additional so i
think maybe that that's a typo we have
confirmed
as councillor jones has said so um these
things happen but
you're right councillor joseph to bring
it up
ruth you wanted to come in here
thank you on page 34 the one before
um i wanted to ask about the council's
investments it's something that i've
been wanting to ask about for ages
um we have only short-term treasury
deposits
i wondered if i could ask julie what if
this is this
normal to only hold i think i was a
months
bonds aren't they we hold are we losing
interest here
is this the normal behavior for councils
and
what what do you think about it oh gosh
and
first of all i should qualify this that
i'm not a treasury advisor so i can't
possibly advise the council on there on
their appropriate sort of treasury
profile
and the short answer is it's it's a very
it's a very mixed picture and it
and some of this reflects on you know
the available balances that individual
authorities
have some will be dependent on the the
risk appetite of individual
authorities so yes we have situations
where
um similar to storage where we have
examples of authorities that just have
some very basic
short-term investments um no borrowing
right through to you know authorities
that have um
you know investments in external
companies um
as well as you know sort of pooled
investments
et cetera so um i don't think there's a
one-size-fits-all approach that's the
whole principle of the council's um
treasury management strategy to decide
about
you know how it chooses to to um
manage its its treasury position over
over the course of the year so
i wouldn't want to kind of um you know
put put the council in particular
bucket and say that's the right or wrong
thing to do you have to reflect
you know what what feels right for the
count of the time and obviously will be
guided by your your section 151 officer
so
um all i'm saying is that there are
plenty of other authorities out there
that just have a very similar profile to
what to what tolerated her from my
experience
you'd like to come in there wouldn't you
yes i mean
council craig i mean obviously the
policy the treasury management policy is
approved by full council and as officers
of the council we've got to
abide by that and obviously we've
slightly changed it now to
have the default that we do ethical
short-term investments
as a default position but i don't know
maybe before your time on the council
i'm not entirely sure when it was it
wasn't too far back
we actually had um something went to
council about investing in what's called
um
property funds and the
council has rejected that as an option
available to us
as officers um maybe with hindsight now
with what's happened with um
property and the like of the pandemic
that might have been a wise decision
but what i'm saying is it did go and so
the policies
ultimately is approved by you as as
councillors
and that's what we operate the
environment we operate
just to clarify as well on our
short-term investments it's up to 12
months so it's basically a year or less
and less so our policy doesn't allow us
to go over the year
but in the main that generally six to
three to six months is the most common
thank you okay right back to you again
julie if you have anything
um chair that there's nothing further
from my sub really so other than to
um you know sort of receive um
confirmation
from from from members that that they're
happy with with the report
and then we will obviously take that
forward as part of our um
our ongoing planning right i believe we
just note this report
um so unless there's any
voices to the country um the report is
truly noted
and we go forward item nine tourist
district
audit plan and again back to you julie
pages 56 to 79.
yeah thank you very much indeed and and
and this just follows on really from
some of the discussion we've already had
both with the progress reports
um and with the inform the risk
assessment so
we have put together a draft plan based
on what we understand of the council
up until now um and where we think the
sort of key areas of focus will be
from from our perspective this year um
as far as the actual accounts themselves
are concerned that the good news is
there aren't
um any significant changes from the
council side in terms of
any big accounting standards changes or
any changes to the local government
um accounting code of practice that that
david and his colleagues will need to
use to actually prepare the account
so no big accounting changes to deal
with this year
um there have been some some some
changes with the auditing standards
so um part of the reason why we went
through the informing the risk
assessment
uh with you is that one of the biggest
changes coming through for the auditing
side of things this year is
there's a new waterton standard around
estimates
and us understanding more about
um management's processes for
determining its estimates
and and how it derives those estimates
for those big numbers in the account so
we're talking predominantly here
you know your valuations of all your
property um
and also your pensions liability
resources valued by by your actuaries
there are some obviously some other
estimates that that management make but
certainly those the most
significant ones and so um we will need
to undertake further work this year in
response to those new requirements of
the standards
um in addition to that the plan
obviously makes reference to the new
value for money code so
um so just goes into that um in a bit
more detail
so um in terms of our significant risks
for the audit that we have
provisionally um proposed to you as you
can see i'm on page 60 which
sets out the introduction and headlines
um we have um uh
the revenue and expenditure recognition
there's there's a
a rebuttable um uh risk within the
autism standards that says
is there an increased level of risk of
fraud within
uh within the organization that's a
mandatory risk under the auditing
standards unless we
are satisfied that with the controls
that you have in place that we can rebut
that
um which i'm pleased to say we can in in
your case
um the second risk around management
override controls again that's a
mandatory risk that we are required to
want to take work on under the auditing
standards
and that particularly is looking at
areas of where you know management have
processed any journals or any senior
officers have been involved
in making any changes to the accounts to
um
to potentially override the financial
position we're required to do that in
accordance with the
the isis um and as i said then
the key other areas are where there's
most subjectivity in in those big
numbers so around valuation land and
buildings
valuations that the pensions liability
uh and finally um we're aware the
council this year has
undertaken a transfer in payroll system
so we'll be doing some specific work
this year too
to look at the completeness and accuracy
of the data transfer between the old and
new pensions
so payroll system um as part of our work
as well just to make sure that the
numbers that are then flowing through to
the accounts
um are complete and complete and
accurate
um so we've set up our materiality
levels
um based on um two percent of your um
your prior your gross expenditure
obviously we will update that
materiality when we get the draft
numbers through four
four this year and then in terms of
value for money
whilst our commentary will cover
obviously across all areas
we have to identify those areas which
there is any sort of risk of
significant weakness and and the only
area that we've identified potentially
is around
the financial sustainability and the
financial planning side of things
uh that's a very common one across all
local authorities and obviously reflects
the context of the
the local government sector at the
moment in terms of the challenge
financial position so we will also do
some specific work around that but
obviously we'll pick up
all the other areas that we've talked
about um in my in my earlier
presentations so
um we've we talked about the the audit
logistics in terms of timing
um the um the the government has now
confirmed its timetable for the 2019-20
sorry 2021 audit process um which will
be
to finalize the um the audit by the end
of september
as i said we're scheduled to come in
later in june so
um i don't anticipate any problems in
meeting that time scale
um in terms of the audit fee position
we've set out the um the scale fee
situation with
the um the audit in terms of the fees
for the current year
we will need to revisit the fee position
because of the changes
in the vfm code which obviously will
require additional work
and additional coverage to what we have
delivered previously
we're just in the process of finalizing
the principles of that with the psa at
the moment
and we will obviously communicate that
separately to this audit committee so
as soon as we've agreed the final
figures in principle with psa
and we will um discuss and share that
with you
um so just for you to be aware of that
and obviously the key changes around the
new auditing standards as well um so
i mean that's the sort the headlines
from from the plan obviously the
subsequent pages talk about that in more
detail but um i'm happy to stop there
and happy to take any specific questions
thank you very much that was very
comprehensive julie um
i have an absence of hands so
just checking nobody's coming in late
right
i think we um note your report
and we will move on to the next item and
thank you very much for your attendance
julie very much appreciated
thank you thank you
right we'll move on to item 10 audit
reports issued to date
to receive the report from rob hutchins
the devon audit partnership manager
and these are pages 80 to 84.
all right good afternoon rob and good
afternoon to you chair and good
afternoon
members and with me today is also paul
middlemast
uh paul is our relatively new audit
manager
um and paul will um is slowly taking on
the reins of working with torridge
uh but i'll present these um reports
today
so as i use a kind of summary chair of
the reports have been issued
uh to the committee since our last
meeting um
so as it says in a page 82 of your packs
there four reports been issued
housing renewals creditors nndr and the
main accounting system
um and i would say that all those
detailed reports have been sent through
to the committee beforehand so i'm not
looking to repeat
a lot of the the detail here but on page
83 you can see our conclusions and we're
able to give substantial assurance our
own creditors in the main accounting
system
uh which is our top level of assurance
um perhaps i should just say that those
assurance ratings are now in line with
the uh sit cypher
assurance ratings that uh um have
recommended
so if we look to try to find some
comparisons between ourselves and other
local authorities that should now
be more easy to do and then we give
reasonable assurance on the nndr
but limited insurance on housing
renewals
um and then just in the following pages
particularly um started on page
85 in the packs there we give a little
bit of a
fair detail really in particular the
housing manuals where we gave limited
assurance so
we've made um 10 recommendations to
further improve
uh the practice of the arrangements and
i think the positive thing for me
is that the the recommendation's all
been agreed um so
although we've found things management
have recognized that those things can be
improved upon
and put in place
resolutions to ensure that those issues
that have been identified
can be addressed as i said the other
other pieces of work
uh credito's um uh ndr i've made an
accounting system reasonably positive
assurance
um levels um and so really that just
concludes the work i've done
in the uh the last or since the last
audit committee
so hopefully that's um helpful for
members but very happy to take any
questions that anybody may have
all right thank you very much rob and
welcome to um
for the team but yes these are
previously
circulated reports but i see um ruth you
have your hand raised
would you like to come in there thank
you chair um
on the housing renewals i just wanted to
ask one
a quick question about what eco-flex
top-up grants were
um but also we always every time
we seem to it's it's always in the
housing department
that we have the limited assurance or
whatever
needs improvement can you give me some
idea of what the 10 recommendations were
about
and how you know how much they've been
implemented
um that's your first question i'm afraid
the eco-flex
scheme i can look at some papers and get
a bit more detail i wouldn't want to
mislead you
never heard of it david i don't know if
you've got an answer to this you've got
your hand raised
yes i'll i'll be careful because um
at one point in time i knew in intimate
detail but slowly over time that
knowledge has just dissipated but in
essence houses were identified which
could deal with energy efficiency
like new boilers okay and that was they
were identified by
um the ratings that sometimes when
somebody's you know you sell your house
and it has an energy efficiency rate
yeah they they came for that and i think
the properties were initially identified
by the utility companies in the first
instance they had some incentive they
were
tasked by the government and using some
of their
profits should we say to make houses
more energy efficient
and then they commissioned various
companies who would do this and they
acted as a sort of a broker so to speak
so they would be sending out letters to
people and saying your house has come up
as a category of a house
that's entitled to an energy efficiency
ball and then there were certain
criteria they had to meet
one of them was in terms of how much you
earned i think if you they think the
threshold reviewed more than 30 thousand
pounds you weren't
eligible to get the grant so essentially
eco flex was about putting
energy efficient boilers into people's
houses to increase the energy fitting
the houses
and therefore decrease the amount of
energy that they use from the national
grid so that's essentially what it
was we got additional money to fund that
and then one of the issues we had is
that essentially it's being commissioned
by a third party and then they're making
the claim against the council for the
cash
so i think um on a budgetary side i
think
you might say um councillor craig that
this was all housing
i'd actually say as well that the
finance department perhaps could have
been a bit more supportive with
hindsight
to our colleagues in the housing
department on this particular
incident it wasn't helped that janet
williams also had severe staffing issues
at the time
in terms of somebody off on long term
sick and essentially was trying to
manage
quite a new service a new scheme um a
little bit
understaffed and under resource so i
think it's been unfair to give
housing the full thing i think with
hindsight asked myself and her colleague
look back on what we could have been a
little stepped in a little bit sooner
we stepped in in finance to stop the
spend but we probably should have turned
off the tap sooner if hindsight have
even been perfectly truthful
okay thank you dave yeah did you want to
come back on those
points robert yes of course
um so just looking for the detailed
report there's things like there's a
there's a strategy
um for empty homes um but that strategy
expired in 2015 so there's a need to get
those kind of things up to date
it's not to say the strategy is wrong
but there's a like a refresh and making
sure those sort of things up to date
we found a couple of things in that the
the housing the database that's used for
recording information
uh was slightly inaccurate um so
something about making sure that the
procedure is in place ensure that those
kind of changes
are required are being put through and
then probably the
the main risk we're finding really what
david is talking about in terms of the
battery control
over spending on the eco flex scheme
um so that's why we did the main uh main
for us are the things that we're finding
and then there's a few more um things in
there about
the um validation checks on some of the
grants that are being uh offered and
making sure that that's a robust and
reliable
i mean as i was sitting in the report
there was a a change in how things were
uh delivered um and um i think the key
thing for me is is really as i say
management
recognize those kind of issues and have
put in place the kind of changes that
would
um remedy the issues in other words then
managing the risks that we've identified
thank you another quick question while
i'm on
yep go ahead on page 86 i think
it was on the um the business grants
that we gave out
um it says the majority of businesses
eligible for the business support
did not actually pay any business rates
and hence the council did not hold their
bank detail
it seems to me very regrettable that
we've given out a lot of money to people
who don't actually pay
councilwoman councillor i think you've
jumped ahead into an hour
he's in part two i was just going to cut
in there
oh sorry
i beg your pardon yeah you're right
okay
right um if there are no more questions
on
item 10 which
i don't we will just note those reports
robert and thank you very much
for them and at this juncture
we attend to the forward plan which is
on page
85.
is it going to come up no okay
davis yes it's really a question for
julie really um
we've got in um the audit finding
reports in on the 19th
october would you be confident that we'd
be able to do that sooner
in september because obviously that
would reflect when we would
really probably ideally we would change
that meeting
and bring it forward yes september
september will be
will be deliverable based on the time
scale that we start the audit so yes
happy to move that forward um chair if i
may just add one further comment just
picking up from what i was talking about
earlier in terms of the vfm changes this
year
um it would also be worthless updating
the forward plan for
the january 22 meeting because at the
moment it's referring to the annual
audit letter but obviously under the new
approach that will disappear
so the annual auditors report will now
also go to that
september meeting alongside the audit
finance report so that'll just be a
small change there
okay thank you very much julie thank you
for clarification
right uh claire you'd like to come in
here
yes please um cycle two um
the effectiveness of the amg committee
now bearing in mind there have been uh
considerable changes
to the value for money aspect
of the audit and how we can challenge
ask questions etc and the fact that we
may
or may not have different members of the
audit committee
after the agm um
how are we going to ensure that we have
got the
measures in place to show and
demonstrate we are an effective
committee
are we planning in our schedule
some kind of training introduction or
induction to the workings of the
committee
because you and i both know that people
aren't
knocking on our doors to join this
committee
and when there are changes we want to
make sure that we're all
familiar with the impact on
our audit committee's work
so i just wanted some clarification that
we were putting some things in place
to make sure that we can demonstrate
that we are
and have been an effective committee and
will continue to be so
thank you
right who would like to
respond to that i don't have a hand
okay well we take we take that comment
on board claire
um so that's all we've got on the
forward plan
so we now move to item 12.
which is to vote for the exclusion the
public
and i would like to move that the public
be excluded from the remainder of the
meeting because of the likely disclosure
of exempt
information as defined in schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972.
so i'm happy to propose from the chair
our second class
thank you so over to you kirsty to take
the vote thank you chair
councillor craigie or councillor hackett
paul councillor heppell thor
councillor hudson for councillor jones
for thank you that's unanimous chair